in the last video we took our first look
at the epsilon-delta definition of
limits which essentially says if you
claim that the limit of f of X as X
approaches C is equal to L then that
must mean by the definition that if some
if you were given any positive epsilon
it essentially tells us how close we
want f of X to be to L we can always
find a delta that's greater than 0 it's
essentially telling us our distance from
C such that if X is within Delta of C
then f of X is going to be within
epsilon of L if we can if we can find a
delta for any epsilon then we can say
that this limit that this is indeed the
limit of f of X as X approaches C now I
know what you're thinking this seems all
very abstract I want to somehow use this
thing and what we will do in this video
is use it and to rigorously prove that a
limit actually exists so right over here
I've defined a function f of X it's
equal to 2x everywhere except for X
equals 5 so it's 2x everywhere for all
the other values of X but when X is
equal to 5 it's just equal to X so I
could have really just written 5 I could
have just written 5 there it's equal to
5
when X is equal to 5 it's equal to
itself and so we've got drawn the graph
here everywhere else it looks just like
2 X at X is equal to 5 it's not along
the line to X instead the function is
defined to be that point right over
there
and if I were to tell ask you what is
the limit of what is the limit of X f of
X as X approaches 5 you might think of
it pretty intuitively well let's see the
closer I get to 5 the closer I get to 5
the closer f of X seems to be getting to
10 the closer I get to 5 the closer f of
X seems to be getting to 10 and so you
might fairly intuitively make the claim
that the limit of f of X as X approaches
5 as X approaches 5 really is equal to
10 it looks that way but what we're
going to do is use the epsilon definite
the epsilon-delta definition to actually
prove it and the way that most of these
proofs typically go is we define Delta
in the abstract and then
essentially try to come up with a way
that given any epsilon we can always
come up with a Delta or another way is
we're going to try to describe our Delta
as a function of epsilon not to confuse
you too much but maybe I shouldn't use F
again but Delta equals function function
of epsilon that is defined for any
positive epsilon so you give me an
epsilon I just kind of put it into our
little formula or a little function box
and I will always get you a delta and if
I can do that for any epsilon that'll
always give you a delta where this is
true that if X is within that range of
Delta is within Delta of C then the
corresponding f of X is going to be
within epsilon of L then the limit
definitely exists so let's try to do
that so let's let's let's think about
let's think about being within Delta of
our C so let's think about this right
over here is 5 plus Delta this is 5
minus Delta so that's our range we're
going to think about we're think about
in the abstract at first and then we're
going to try to come up with a kind of a
formula for Delta in terms of Epsilon
so how can we describe all of the X's
that are in this range but not equal to
5 itself because we really care about
the things that are within Delta a 5 but
not necessarily equal to 5 this is just
a strictly less than there within a
range of C but not equal to C well
that's going to be all of the X's that
satisfy X minus 5 is less than is less
than Delta that describes all of these
X's right over here
now what we're going to do and the way
these proofs typically go is we're going
to try to manipulate this let the
left-hand side of the inequality so it
starts to look something like this or it
starts to look exactly like that and as
we do that this the right-hand side of
the inequality is going to be expressed
in terms of Delta and then we can
essentially say well look if the
right-hand side looks like Delta the
left-hand or is in terms of Delta and
the left-hand side looks just like that
that really defines how we can express
Delta in terms of Epsilon if that
doesn't make sense
bear with me I'm about to do it so if we
want if we want X minus 5 to look a lot
more like this when X is
is not equal to five and all of this
this whole interval X is not equal to
five f of X is equal to 2x our limit
that our proposed limit is equal to 10
so if we could somehow get this to be 2x
minus 10 then we're in good shape
and the easiest way to do that is to
multiply both sides of this inequality
by 2 you multiply both sides of this
inequality by 2
and 2 times the absolute value of
something that's the same thing as the
absolute value of 2 times that thing if
I were to say 2 times the absolute value
of a that's the same thing as the
absolute value of 2a so on the left hand
side right over here this is just going
to be the absolute value of 2x minus 10
and it's going to be less than on the
right hand side you just end up with a 2
Delta now what do we have here on the
left hand side well this is f of X as
long as X does not equal 5 and this is
our limit so we can rewrite this as f of
X minus L is less than 2 Delta and this
is 4 for X does not equal 4 x does not
equal 5 this is f of X this literally is
our limit now this is interesting this
statement right over here is almost
exactly what we have want right over
here except the right sides are just
different this has in terms of Epsilon
this has it in terms of Delta so how can
we define Delta so that we can put so
that 2 Delta is essentially going to be
Epsilon well this is our chance we will
just define we will we will make we will
make and this is where we're we're we're
defining Delta as a function of Epsilon
we're going to make two Delta equal
epsilon or if you divide both sides by 2
we're going to make Delta equal to
epsilon over 2 so if you make Delta
equal epsilon over 2 so if you make if
you make let me switch colors just to
ease the monotony if you make if you
make Delta equal epsilon over 2 then
this statement right over here becomes
the absolute value of f of X minus L is
less than instead of 2 Delta it'll be
less than
two times epsilon over two is just going
to be is going to be less than Epsilon
so this is the key if someone gives you
any positive number epsilon for this
function as long as you make Delta equal
epsilon over two then any X within that
range that corresponding f of X is going
to be within epsilon of our limit so
this tells you some would say say the
epsilon and remember it has to be true
for any positive epsilon but you could
see how the game could go if someone
gives you the epsilon Epsilon let's say
they want to be within 0.5 of our limit
so our limit is up here so our epsilon
is 0.5 so it literally be the range I
want to be between 10 plus epsilon would
be 10.5 and then 10 minus epsilon would
be 9.5 well we just came up with a
formula we just have to make Delta equal
to epsilon over 2 which is equal to 0.25
so that'll give us a range between four
point seven five four point seven five
and five point two to five and as long
as we pick an x between four point seven
five and five point two five then the
corresponding f of X but not x equals
five the corresponding f of X will be
between nine point five and ten point
five and so you give me any epsilon I
can just apply apply this formula right
over here to come up with the Delta this
would apply for any real number I mean
especially any positive number for any
epsilon you give me I just get a delta
and then a delta defined this way and
then I can go through this arc if X
minus five is less the absolute value of
X minus five is less than Delta if Delta
is defined in this way which I can
define for any epsilon then it will be
the case that f of X will be within
epsilon of our limit